hi and we're back alright I just want to
say Sean Penn my accountants would like
a word with you our next presenter is
the first woman to ever breastfeed an
apple please welcome Academy Award
winner will of Paltrow
I really wanted to provide you with
synopsis of this year's best foreign
language film in their respective
languages but wouldn't you know it there
isn't enough time so here are the
nominees for Best Foreign Language Film
as it is in heaven
from Sweden Kai Paula the chorus from
France
please stuff the high-tier downfall from
germany oliver hirschbiegel the scene
side from Spain Alejandro Amenabar
yesterday in South Africa Daryl
and the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes
to
estefania for Mar adentro accepting the
award this is the fourth Academy Award
and nineteenth nomination for Spain
thank you so much this is this film is
based on a man who despite his desire
for death spread so much life around him
so the first third part of this award
goes for him belongs to him whatever he
is the second third part is for Javier
Bardem for his outstanding performance
and his generosity and the another third
part goes to of course my friend and
producer Fernando ADA to the fabulous
cast and crew for being so focused on
these movies since the very beginning
and as for me I'm just so pleased
because it seems that I'm in charge of
keeping it in one piece for the rest of
my life so thank you so much
please welcome coach Carter Academy
Award nominee samuel l.jackson
you